[Musique]
les essentiels du
Sénat lutter contre la surpopulation
carcérale avec un taux d'incarcération
de 115 % la France est le 3è pays de
l'Union européenne à la plus forte
densité de population
carcérale cette situation conduit à des
conditions de détention indignes pour
les personnes détenues et difficilement
supportable pour les personnes de
l'administration
pénitentiaire pour tenter de remédier à
ce problème structurel le gouvernement a
annoncé en 2018 la création de 15000
places de prison et de 20 centres
éducatifs fermés pour la réinsertion des
jeunes délinquants d'ici
2027 5 ans après la mise en œuvre de ces
deux plans d'investissement immobilier
la commission des finances a souhaité
faire un bilan d'étapes Antoine Lefèvre
rapporteur spécial des crédits de la
mission justice pointe des problèmes de
délais et de cût dans les exécution du
plan
15000 le budget du plan 15000 a été
progressivement augmenté il atteint déjà
5,55 milliards d'euros en juin 2023 soit
une hausse de 30 % par rapport au coût
initialement prévu certains projets
comme le centre pénitentiaire d'Anger ou
de Baster connaissent d'importants
dérapages budgétaires et calendaires
quant aux 20 centres éducatif fermés
prévu dont le budget a déjà presque
quadruplé seulement trois ont été
achevés et 5 autres n'ont même pas
encore de sitite attribués pour leur
construction parce qu'ils répondent au
double impératif d'améliorer la prise en
charge des détenus et des mineurs ainsi
que les conditions de travail des
personnels ces projets doivent pourtant
être menés à bien à cet effet le
rapporteur spécial formule 12
propositions concrètes il recommande
notamment d'associer les organisations
professionnelles et le secteur
associatif habilité à l'élaboration des
plans de construction ou de rénovation
des établissements pénitentiaires et des
ces centres éducatifs fermés il défend
le déploiement d'équipe test sur les
chantiers pour remédier le plus en amont
possible au défauts majeurs de
conception deux autres des
préconisations consistent à créer un
vrai comité d'audit pour suivre ses
plans d'investissement de grande ampleur
et à soutenir la revalorisation des
personnels le rapporteur conclut
néanmoins que la politique pénitentiaire
ne peut se résumer à une politique
immobilière au 1er juillet 2023 plus de
74000 personnes étaient dé et écroué le
plan 15000 ayant été conçu pour une
population carcérale de 75000 personnes
en 2027 cela veut dire que les capacités
du parc seront probablement saturées
avant même l'achèvement du
plan pour en savoir plus consultez le
site Internet du
Sénat